The joe rogan experience,
um,
playing on the song.
Yeah,
sure.
I got like reacclimate myself.
So you want to play this on?
I'm chanting like recently an uplifting one,
but yeah.
Shit.
No,
you don't have to clean up questions.
If you want to make the folks cry,
maybe we'll have a little yin and Yang.
A high and low whenever you want.
I'm going to put some Yang.
Can I make a request?
We may not be able to fulfill it,
but you can put dare you.
How's that?
Not Possible.
Um,
will you guys play La River?
I mean,
yeah.
Yeah.
Clean it up.
I fucking love that song.
Sure
you want to do it right now.
Okay,
here we go.
Here we go.
I'm going to try something.
That's one of the cool things about music.
You guys can take requests,
have comedians take requests.
Wouldn't play this in a while.
I really try not to mess it.
Let's just Thunderpussy that.
That kind of requests is great.
Maybe you just play
okay.
Okay.
What can we do it in GI?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
I got this
now to the banks of the
chain link fence.
Concrete walls on the
Oh
oh listen to the big city.
Sound
well down bad chains.
Fast chat at town.
MMM
fingers.
Danny
got us a body.
Oh,
they see,
Gotcha.
Pass Chan town.
Oh Man.
Oh,
nice to the big city.
Sam Down.
Bad Chains Pass Janet's dad.
Ah,
Oh shit.
We got through that one.
Yeah,
that was great.
I love that fucking song.
That was bad.
A house.
Holy Shit.
That was really cool,
man.
I looked the banjos making a comeback.
I'd like that big 10.